[Music]
my talk is on pythonic polling my name
is Daley Nielsen I'm a software engineer
from New York City I actually work at a
health tech startup so I'm not a
professional pollster nor do I have
professional polling experience so you
should take all this as the views of a
very passionate amateur but not a
professional pollster I did take three
months off to work for the Hillary
Clinton campaign at the very end of the
election cycle I obviously find a very
strict non-disclosure so anything I say
here is just my own opinion and has
nothing to do with the work I did on the
campaign but let's get started as you
know we had two massive political
surprises or upsets from the angle of
speaking world this year we had brexit
and then we had the election of Donald
Trump
in both cases I think pollsters were
very much maligned and people talked
about these as these catastrophes as far
as polling going right now expressing
the political opinion but just saying
what the heck do pollsters do why is it
go so wrong and what can we do about it
so I wanted to talk a little bit about
that and also just give a general primer
for the Python community so for people
who are thinking about getting involved
you have a sense of sort of how things
work right now and I think you'll see
there's a lot of work to do and a lot of
sophistication that could be brought to
bear that isn't necessarily what's going
on now so let's get started first with
an inspirational quote it's tough to
make predictions especially about the
future Yogi Berra an American baseball
player / genius but you might actually
think you've heard this quote from
someone else and you probably have
because Samuel Goldwyn also got credited
never make predictions especially about
the future and then Niels Bohr of all
people prediction is very difficult
especially about the future so I just
want to remind you that we should be
kind to pollsters this is a very
difficult problem it's also like a very
low data problem right so you're asked
to make predictions about very volatile
situations with very little data both as
far as the data you have about a
particular year but also just the
history of the data right so the u.s.
oldish democracy right we haven't had
that many election
cycles if you think about it right so if
you want to do something like sentiment
analysis of a thousand books or stock
market predictions where you have
measurements every millisecond right
that's a much easier problem in a lot of
ways the goals for this talk better
understanding of the nuts and bolts of
what pollsters do a better understanding
of the uncertainty in polls and also how
much goes on disclosed right
increasingly people are finding that
polls themselves become news stories but
the news story is always just about the
top lines right oh we see that today 53%
of people want brexit or 72% of people
in this district want Donald Trump etc
they don't usually tell you how they got
that top line right the news story tends
to be about just that one number plus
what that might mean for the election or
the country or whatever it doesn't tend
to tell you how they got there even
though there's a lot of art and a lot of
discretion that goes into generating
that number and you can really generate
any number depending on what you decide
is a reasonable assumption and finally a
better understanding of how the pie data
community can contribute I think there's
a lot of work that can be done in my
experience R is really leading the
charge right now but I'd really like to
see Python catch up so people decide
these are interesting problems or things
they'd like to write about that would be
great
here's an outline of what I want to talk
about why does polling matter a little
bit of history what has changed very
very recently which is probably relevant
to what we saw this year brexit in the
u.s. presidential how polls work how
polls of close work what can go wrong
and what did go wrong and maybe what we
should do about it so firstly why does
polling matter there's a bunch of
reasons right we all have our own
reasons here are a few that are
important to me
surprises aren't good right so if we
look here we see the trading share price
of RBS it took a real hit right after
the brexit results and didn't really
recover right away that's not so great
right if I were running that business or
if I were an employee of that business
I'd be really upset about the surprise
right and for all we know people lost
their jobs or didn't get the promotion
they were looking forward and get to
start some new business possibility
because of this what is arguably even
worse
a shock like the one we see the barclays
share price right where it drops they
got this horrible scare again and I'm
not saying I know what happened but you
could imagine people lost their jobs or
business plans got cancelled and then
they kind of recovered anyway right so
you have this shock that wasn't even
economically informative so one way is
in polling matters is we can avoid these
sorts of economic shocks that destroy
value hurt people's lives etc another
one is for the functioning of democracy
right we want to hear from the
electorate if you are a representative
in either the UK or the US right your
ratio of representatives to people is
it's not really fathomable right I can't
fathom a one to a hundred thousand or
one to a million or one to an 80 million
kind of representation but that's what
some of these representatives are asked
to do or people who are running for
office are asked to do an example of how
these polls can then be helpful is for
example there was one done by the
Monmouth University poll actually during
the primaries which is when the u.s. is
parties are deciding who they're even
going to run in the main event and they
pulled things on such as well what's
important to you right so they won't
just ask who you're going to vote for or
who you're leaning for they'll also ask
how are you making that decision and so
for example they found that people in
New Hampshire who identified as
Democrats found it more important to
prioritize shared values rather than
electing a winnable candidate so that
was information both for the candidates
as far as how they wanted to sell
themselves and also information even for
the candidate who would be elected right
what is important to the people who just
elected me right was it important that I
just be able to win and that I keep
winning or is it important that I show
them we care about the same thing it's
also important because otherwise it's
not that easy to get through to your
electors so right after the election of
Donald Trump and in the first days of
office there's been an incredible
outpouring of political activity you've
probably even seen coverage here people
are just much more active much more
likely to reach out to their
representatives and they're finding that
it's actually not that easy to do right
because most of the time people don't
email or call their representatives it
actually turns out that the calling
system of the US Congress gets
overloaded really really easily so the
Congress can't tell if there's a
thousand people calling them or 10,000
people calling them or 100,000 people
calling this
system gets saturated and so many ways
of measuring how people feel other than
poles are really antiquated and really
not built for a time of the political
season when people are really active and
trying to give feedback so poles are
maybe the only way where you can really
let the entire electorate speak if they
wish to also for finding out what the
electorate knows they're believed so
this is a headline I saw from the UK
shock poll shows voters believe you kit
is to the left of Tories right so
sometimes you will find out that what
people think about you is not even what
you're trying to sell or what what you
thought was true right and so you find
out that the electorate's beliefs or
knowledge is not what you are thinking
and you need that shared understanding
or you're really not going to go
anywhere
also on hearing the electorate in the
u.s. we have a US Census poll that goes
out every year to some non-trivial
portion of the population we get this
info in we generate tabulations the
control spending this is how most
countries try to allocate their
resources right so that's important
money right the Clinton Trump contest
probably spent about 2.6 5 billion when
you count everything paying the
pollsters paying for ads paying for
logistics etc so it's big money in the
UK the actual cost of holding an
election is over a hundred million
pounds so pretty expensive most of the
time also this spending is trending up
even adjusted for inflation especially
in the US it's really trending up in the
UK is up and down a little more but the
point is we could be curing cancer with
this money rather than always holding
elections so to the extent that polls
can give us a way to avoid elections or
to better inform our representatives
they are very useful also on the money
front and going back to the anti you
know anti-shock not liking financial
shock things let's remember it's not
just the home countries that pay right
so the UK pays for their elections or
the u.s. pays for their elections and
maybe we just spend the money internally
and it's great but you can also have
cases where boom we just dropped some
huge portion of the Mexican pesos value
right and again even if this were to
happen right it would have been nicer
for it to be a gradual decline rather
than a shock where people wake up and
find out that their retirement savings
is worth 10 percent less than it was a
day before and they hadn't even had time
to brace for it or say move out of that
currency
I'm happy to say a Mexican peso has
almost recovered from that so again it's
a case where they had to shock and maybe
recovered but I would argue that's even
worse right it was a shock that wasn't
necessary and arguably wasn't
informative and finally voter
orientation right everyone wants to know
what everyone thinks this is a way to do
it people don't always talk about
politics in public fora so it's good to
have a way to express what you're
thinking you can also have crowd wisdom
or the bandwagon effect right people use
what other people think as a way of
deciding what they think good for the
good or the bad
exit polls might even cause changes in
voter behavior and there is some
suggestion that the very strong forecast
in the US and this past election cycle
also influenced you saw either voter
behavior and so there's this possibility
that you have a feedback system so polls
are important because we think they're
important that's another way of thinking
about polls and more evidence for that
is two of the biggest polling websites
in the u.s. got 200 million site visits
in October alone right so it's big
business but it's also just a massive
area of interest okay a little bit of
history about polling first non
political polls are American I think no
offense to the UK I think Americans are
really the Emperors of polling as far as
we spend the most money on it we seem
really obsessed with it it did start in
the u.s. even the first polls that were
massively off so in the very first poll
that is recorded in 1824 Andrew Jackson
had 70 percent of the votes in the straw
poll but he only won by forty one
percent right so you can see that these
things can be really off right because
people self-select into these sorts of
polls for about a hundred years this
straw polling which is just
self-selection polling was the norm
it was very local and just like now
polling was very newspaper driven right
so even now lots of polling is just done
by news organizations because polls are
news it was the same a hundred years ago
modern polling really got to start with
the literary digest and started polling
in 1928 they had an enormous mailing
list just from their subscribers so they
actually got within four percent of the
actual vote that was huge nobody had
ever done that before so they were sort
of celebrated as geniuses they did it
again four years later they had an even
bigger
mailing this and they got within 2% of
the outcome which is actually a state of
the art even now right we have sampling
error you can only get so good no matter
what so they were just the big geniuses
the problem was is that in 1936 the
election was a disaster literally I just
thought the bigger the better right in
their first prediction they had done
really well they got an even bigger
mailing list they didn't even better
then they got an even bigger mailing
this they went beyond their own
subscribers and what did they do they
looked at phone directories and they
look at car registration lists so that
they could amp their list up to 10
million people I see you nodding what's
what's the problem with this in 1936
absolutely and especially in 1936 right
this is like John Steinbeck the year of
the Depression people are out on the
street right they don't have cars normal
people don't have cars and they probably
don't even have telephones they can't
afford them they've been kicked out of
their houses etc etc so what you got was
this group of very wealthy people who
even had the money for the stamp to
return the survey to tell you who they
thought was going to win and so they
actually predicted a massive landslide
in the wrong direction
and that was sort of the end of the
literary digest political polling this
is when Gallup polling took off in the
US and the UK they had done uphold the
same year it didn't have these
self-selection effects I don't think
they did fantastic but they did call the
winner and they only got better from
there right because they understood
these problems of self selecting it
which are intuitive problems that we all
understand but to put this in historical
perspective let's remember that
statistics and the things that we all do
now for a living are very very new
pearson's chi-squared test is only 1900
students t-test is only 1908 Oxford had
its Institute of Statistics in 1935
Harvard in 1957 statistics is pretty new
so in a way you have to forgive people
for not thinking about the problems and
also not knowing how to quantify them
even if they had thought about them
so that's polling what has changed
recently in polling response rates have
plummeted so in the 70s they were as
high as 80% people were super polite to
each other you call me up and you want
to know how what I think in them I'm
like you know so touch that you want to
know what I think and I'm happy to tell
you very earnestly I mean I'm
exaggerating a bit but it's amazing
now to think that a few decades ago you
call people and they were happy to talk
to you and they would tell you what they
thought and very few would you know sort
of hang up the phone on you that's not
so true now it's low single-digit so the
polls from 2016 were 8% 9% 10% response
rates and that's what people were
willing to admit to right so when you
think about the fact that they're not
required to report response rates you
realize it could be a lot lower than
that also the percentage of Americans
without any landline has more than
doubled in the last ten years so half of
Americans don't have a landline now
that's the problem because most polling
sampling still takes place over
landlines people are trying to move to
have a mix the people who don't have
landlines versus the people who do are
obviously very very different people and
especially in this election they had
very very different voting preferences
but we don't quite know how much right
how different because then you'd have to
do a whole study of landline versus cell
users when it's all empirical and it can
all change right and it's all changing
rapidly now for example in 2016 half of
Americans don't have landlines but 10
years ago it was only like 10 percent
right so again it's this rapid growth
and we don't know quite how rapid until
recently live telephone interviews as I
was alluding to used to provide the best
results right so there were there was
internet polling there's also sort of
Robo calling which is we believe
regulated in the US but is allowed on
landlines historically telephone
interviews were doing the best but that
actually wasn't true either for the EU
referendum or for the u.s. presidential
election so it also is changing even
from 2012 election cycle in the u.s. too
now we are finding that what might be
the best way of getting at people in a
representative way or even in the least
non representative way is changing okay
rested in the u.s. presidential I think
we all at least vaguely remember these
events from this year but just a quick
recap of what we were expecting on
Election Day so this graphic here I have
a you go VIN it so this Mori prediction
these were election day predictions for
the EU referendum and also the New
Statesman had published the current
betting odds from financial markets and
betting websites so either from polling
or from crowdsourcing it was looking
very good for a remain although to the
pollsters credit they were
always saying it was within the margin
of error and that's one of the lessons I
think we know is all gotten lost
everyone's angry but no one has
remembered that they always said there
was this margin of error that was larger
than the spread okay so was it wrong
we'll talk more about that later the
u.s. presidential also I think this one
was an even bigger surprise because
there were so many fancy models saying
Hillary Clinton has a 97 percent chance
to win 85 percent chance to win the most
pessimistic model actually put her
chances at 70% that was Nate silver and
he was constantly attacked for it and
had to write many blog posts explaining
that he wasn't just trying to undercut
her or make her look bad more on that
later for those who don't know how the
electoral college works or the u.s.
system remember it's not a direct
democracy so we have the system where in
your state you vote and then that gets
carried forward so it's not as simple as
winning the popular vote
so was that wrong we'll get back to that
so let's talk a bit more about how polls
work right if you want to start building
programs the first thing is sampling
right so I talked about this this has
been very important in the history of
polling you can have a probability
sample versus a non probability sample
right we started with nonprobability
sampling in the history of political
polling right so nonprobability sampling
you can have something like a quota
sample maybe you are a company and you
want to know what people think about
perfume so you tell your assistant go
out and talk to 200 people and don't
come back until you get those 200 people
that's massively messed up right because
the first people you're going to get are
going to be really easy but if you're
really trying to get that 200 you're
going after increasingly special people
you get this really skewed distribution
similarly if you do accidental or
convenience sampling which we see a lot
right newspaper guy goes out on the
street he just talks like what is the
man on the street thing right depends
what neighborhood it depends he wanted
to talk to him etc these sorts of things
though are used for political polling
right Internet poll what else could it
possibly be except an accidental
sampling right did you go to my website
did you agree to do my poll massive self
selection for this reason you might see
margins of error that are calculated but
these are not true margins of error
reflecting sampling error right there's
nothing statistical you can do here
without making tons of assumptions all
you can do is build your statistical
model based on how you think people sell
elected in and give that so when you see
Internet poll of giving you a top line
and maybe a margin of error that is
completely made-up not to criticize
right but just to say people have put
their worldview of what is reasonable
there is not some sort of single way to
calculate that number or for that number
to mean a single thing better is
probability sampling so you can do this
in a few ways probability sampling is
very expensive so you can do cluster
sampling where you sort of figure out if
I go to these five neighborhoods this
will be approximately London or
approximately the UK or approximately
the US and sort of try to do that as
rigorously as you can you can do
stratified random sampling where you
decide on the buckets of types of people
right I want I want you know five
percent white females in London I want
seventeen percent Hispanic males from 18
to 34 in new york city etc most common
is what we call random digit dialing
where you just literally randomly dial
phone numbers in the US this works
really well for landlines because you
know where people are it's working less
and less well now that cell phones don't
tend to have much to do with where
people live for example I have a cell
phone that is connected to a city I only
lived in for three months and I don't
think I'm that unusual
okay so why does sampling matter and why
is sampling the crux of the issue well
let's look at the LA Times poll tracker
for the u.s. 2016 presidential election
you can see they were looking at White's
right and not surprisingly or very
well-known Trump had a much larger share
of white support he's in red it's very
smooth though right what you'll notice
is there's a couple of ups and downs and
maybe they had to do with certain news
coverage etc you get a bump post
convention but it's really smooth right
people tended to know who they were
going to vote for there were some
undecided but the portion of undecideds
also stayed about the same so if we
think like this is the largest share of
the u.s. electorate it doesn't look like
this was a crazy election if I look at
the black sampling though wow it's
jumping up and down and people might
have seen a bit of news coverage about
this right like the one black male
supporter of Trump in Indiana etc and
when when you catch that guy these
numbers really go up and down
and I mean if you look at professional
polling results and when people disclose
their weightings sometimes you see that
that one black 18 to 34 year old in
Indiana who supports Trump because he's
the only one in his little bucket might
have been up waited to represent a
thousand people right whereas like a
white woman in her thirties like me is
very happy to pick up the phone and talk
but like my political leanings are like
very plain vanila i exactly conform to
what i should my weighting might be like
point one and this guy's waited a
thousand or 10,000 and to see things
jumping up and down and so just looking
at this you can also get a sense of who
responds the most in the least right so
clearly whites are happy to talk to
pollsters blacks less happy to talk to
pollsters or less likely to I shouldn't
actually make assertions about their
effect Latino somewhere in the middle so
what do you guys think raise your hand
if you think women talk to pollsters
more raise your hand if using men talk
to posters more okay well it's actually
the women it's always been that way it
will probably always be that way but you
can see here the men actually jump up a
bit like the blacks t right like the
portion of men who talk to pollsters is
much more than the portion of women so
another thing to keep in mind right like
the male vote was actually fairly
important in the election but as we can
see it probably wasn't sampled very well
because it was jumping around so
sampling error I think everyone knows a
bit about this you incur this whenever
the statistical characteristics of a
population when you're trying to
estimate this this always happens with
polling as a reminder there's the
formula and the biggest thing to
remember is it's just really really hard
to cut down on your margin of error
right so sometimes people will be
irritated why is it plus or minus 3% I
mean if you look at this graph just
going from 4,000 to 5,000 participants
in my polling I've really I've gone down
like what like a third of a percent a
half of a percent like it's almost like
why bother right to make an intelligent
statement about the election I'm almost
as doing as well sampling far less than
a thousand then paying much much more
money to sample 5,000 and hardly do
better and possibly still not be able to
call it to put this in perspective also
a live telephone interview on a national
sample in the u.s. runs around a hundred
thousand dollars so it's a hundred
thousand dollars to be around here right
I'm pretty sure the cost to get
to 5,000 would be at least five that and
five times that and probably more rights
if you'd be working increasingly hard to
get people it's not that easy to find
people who want to talk to pollsters
especially with swing states where
people are constantly getting called
okay so you're responsible almost never
reflect your population distribution
unless you tamper with them and that's
actually what pollsters do I don't mean
tamper is a bad word but actually their
whole job really is the weighting the
pollsters themselves the people who talk
on television don't actually talk to
people or not usually they take these
massive contingency tables and they
adjust them and there's a bunch of ways
you can adjust them no way is required
some of them are more straightforward
than others so the easiest one to
understand and the most sort of
automatic is designed weights usually
some demographic groups will be expected
to have low response rates they just
always have researchers will usually
sample these groups at higher rates
precisely because I don't want to end up
with one black 18 to 34 year old Trump
supporter in Indiana
I'd rather get more right so that I can
at least get some sense of how uniform
they are so I might sample black 18 to
34 year old males in Indiana at 10 times
the rate of white female 30 year olds
from Indiana right just because I know
that's approximately their difference in
responses I'm then going to use my
design weights which just means re
calibrating to reflect the fact that I
sample that 10x I always want to end up
with a proportion that reflects the
population I wanna say population I
don't really mean the population though
right I mean the people who are going to
vote not everyone so that's design
weights post ratification is when you're
going to just explicitly account for the
differential response so you might over
sample certain groups but you might
still not be able to get them so post
ratification is what you do to fix the
data up after you have differential
responses you will get different
responses from those different groups so
you can just plan on this rather than
over sampling and this is also quite
intuitive for example say that I have
10% population no formal education but
5% sample I'm just going to wait that by
- right to bring it up to my population
note that this will sometimes be
modified by hard upper limits right so
if I get a five a ten a thousand a
10,000 for a person I might just say I'm
going to cap it at five in the u.s. we
use the American Community Survey to do
our weightings it's a very expensive
demographic measure
of the population so all the info that
pollsters use is publicly available
sometimes though variables that you know
will sway people are not variables that
are available in a joint distribution in
this case you might know age and sex but
not education raking will allow you to
adjust to the marginals right so if I
know how these things should come out
but not these middle numbers I can use
what's called iterative proportional
fitting to sort of adjust them and it's
called raking because I go column by
column to make things fit one way and
then make them fit another way
convergence is not guaranteed it is
pretty good this is fairly
computationally taxing because you're
usually going to have high dimension
problems but it's actually this very
simple idea of just going through and
slowly adjusting so the 2d as you can
see in Python is super fast especially
with non PI right I just have some
arrays I sum them up and I divide by the
appropriate numbers there's also a
package IP FN in a iterative
proportional fitting this is also very
easy to use it's a very common technique
finally there's something called
multi-level regression and post
stratification this is when you want to
predict for small area that's very
useful in the US right I might want to
know what Rhode Island this tiny state
is thinking but I only have national
data or I might just want a better
explanatory sense of what variables
contribute in that case I'm going to
gather national opinion polls get region
level predictors get the data for the
post stratification do a load it
regression and then rather than using my
actual polling samples only from Rhode
Island to predict Rhode Island I can
actually use the whole country say to
get that small area estimate in practice
every poll you see is using one of these
techniques you're going to rarely see
individual pre rated results people
don't tend to release those they don't
tell you what their actual sample looks
like they also don't tell you their
weight you also won't usually see many
scenarios right so what you see here is
there's at least three different ways
people can wait there's some discretion
within those I can sort of cut off tails
or whatever I want to do and you won't
see unweighted polls right so the idea
is everything you're seeing has an
unknown multiplier your margins of error
also should be adjusted to reflect your
weighting procedures we don't actually
know if people do that but they should
it's actually not easy to adjust your
margin of error
raking or multi regression and post
ratification so when in doubt you should
simulate right that's always the easy
thing to do that's part of why we use
Python okay so how do polls with polls
work these tend to be different ways of
looking at time series of polls coming
from many providers you can use a
weighted moving average the lowest
common filter or more complicated models
I'm running out of time so I'm actually
going to skip over this and just talk
about what some fairly famous polls you
would have seen have done so the
Financial Times for example all this
info is available it's good to start
looking for it the FT polls of polls is
calculated by taking the last seven
polls from unique pollsters up to a
given date removing the two polls with
the highest lead four remain and leave
in calculating the adjusted average of
the five every moment meaning polls
where the more recent polls are given a
higher weight right so you can see
they've got their own little way of
doing it what about the US a couple of
examples the HuffPo uses a common filter
and Monte Carlo simulation you usually
have to do some kind of simulation in
the US because you have state-by-state
polls and then you have to combine them
all you don't just have one top line The
Economist uses a Louis buy sample size
gets their error rate from historic
polls and then does a Monte Carlo
simulation 538 which was the most
accurate in this election in the sense
of they were the most optimistic about
the Trump victory they have their own
very complicated and too like everyone's
secret way of doing this but they do
tell you that they account for recency
they account for pollster reputation
they seem to do a lot of work and a lot
of legwork as far as just making sure
their inputs are really good which
arguably other people don't do more
relying on the weights you can see this
is all public knowledge I know as much
as anyone because they put it out here
not because I talk to people of these
organizations so they are fairly
transparent as far as what their
techniques are the economists 538 so
everyone does do that and you can
actually do your own polls the pollster
API almost everyone uses this all
professional organizations news related
or business if they're not running their
own polls they're getting free polling
data from the pollster API it's got a
Python client so it's awesome ok so I am
desperately running out of time but I am
going to talk a little bit about what
went wrong firstly arguably nothing
the results were always really close you
got explicitly said the results are
close and it's too early to call but
they got all sorts of nasty comments
nonetheless which feels a little unfair
for brexit most pollsters said it was
too close to call
you could always up your sample size but
hey that's expensive and be at some
point that's just like having an
election right like if your poll has to
have an election to call the election
there's really no point to it while
Internet polling did do better this time
it has in the past so this is something
we may need to adjust for but we don't
know just from one data point that
that's true sampling error is hard and
expensive to reduce what about the u.s.
election well let's remember the
election came down to 77 thousand votes
at the end right a seventy seven
thousand votes had gone the other way
the outcome would have been different
that's also something that hasn't been
sufficiently covered but there was
correlated error right what went wrong
with the polls the national polls were
fine but the state-by-state polls were
actually horribly wrong in certain cases
and from what people have seen so far
this is because Trump supporters were
undersampled
in the relevant states it wasn't that
they weren't telling the truth that they
were lying that they were saying they
weren't going to vote and that they did
it's actually that people didn't
necessarily call them for a whole bunch
of reasons also there was a higher
proportion of an undecided voters than
there ever has been before pollsters are
not used to dealing with this it's hard
to predict future behavior if you have
no similar past behavior to learn from
and also correlated errors are not easy
to diagnose until after the fact right
so they might be if you have like a
massive time series like this you can
start like fitting regression lines or
trend lines and seeing that the way
errors move is it's not spread out
randomly right they're all sort of going
in the same direction not really clear
how you can do that with polling right
you only have maybe ten data points even
if you sampled for 10 weeks
strangely folks did try to be proactive
looking for these correlation
correlation but they failed right so
people were thinking about this
possibility especially in terms of maybe
Trump voters thinking their choice would
not be socially desirable but they
didn't actually find result proof for
this and even ex-post there hasn't been
any proof for this so nobody really
knows where exactly the correlated error
came from except that nobody did it on
purpose and people did think they
appalling people reliably there were
also unknown turnout effects of models
forecasting greater than 90% probability
of Clinton victory there have never been
such strong forecasts so while in the
past these sorts of forecasts have not
influenced motor behavior we have never
had a case where the forecasts were so
strong right so it is possible that
people said oh it's a 90 percent chance
of victory I'm late for work like I'm
really not going to go vote and so
there's going to be new political work
on that right it's one thing to say
someone has a 60% chance of winning and
you think you better go but when it
starts being 90 that could be a whole
different kind of behavior okay so what
we should do about it if people don't
want to talk to pollsters where can we
go to get the public pulse online polls
did really well they're also really
cheap so it's a hundred thousand dollars
versus five thousand or less we're
definitely going to be moving towards
online polling as a society whether we
like it or not so it's good if we can
start thinking about what kind of online
polling we want to do there's also other
free sources of data right and a lot of
those free sources of data are turning
up in presentations at this conference
because they're so abundant right like
Twitter Google reddit Facebook Twitter
is a great source of free ish
information there are businesses sort of
starting to build businesses right with
their data but for now you can say they
actually did a pretty good job of
calling some of the elections right so
for example if you look at the positive
and negative breakfast coverage actually
Twitter was calling it for breakfast or
for the leave option the breakfast
option a few weeks before the election
and by a fairly large margin if you
looked at the positive versus negative
effect displayed on Twitter for remain
versus leave it didn't do quite as well
in the u.s. election so this is an
example people looked at emoticon
emotions we can see here that they did
an okay job at predicting where Bernie
Sanders would win over Hillary Clinton
for example people in Minnesota really
didn't like Hillary Clinton and that
showed when they had their caucuses and
keep in mind this is four months before
the election so if this turns out to be
a useful signal that's really great
similarly people really didn't like
Trump again for months before their
primaries are no this isn't December
2015
Nevada was supposed to be close but
actually Nevada was a victory for
Hillary by a large margin largest margin
so we can see here that maybe maybe this
angry face and emoticons means something
similarly the Twitter just a sentiment
analysis of the language not the
Americans also might have helped call
right so we can see that coverage of
Trump tended to be more positive on
Twitter than coverage of Clinton also
the ratios were very different so on the
Left we have Clinton on the right we
have Trump we have red is negative and
green is positive and we can see it was
it was a very negative election but
Trump clearly had higher green to red
ratio right people clearly were more
tolerant of Chomper had less negative
effect relative to their positive effect
another big topic was free SH was free
news coverage right what's called earned
media Trump got tremendous amounts of
earned media meaning he didn't have to
pay for ads everything he said made it
to the front page maybe that's one of
the indicators that someone's going to
win they're making news so if we look at
Google Trends right for Donald Trump
versus Hillary Clinton Trump was really
killing it especially like the week of
the election he has like four or five
times the number of Twitter searches of
Hillary Clinton maybe that was a signal
that should have been incorporated or
maybe not because the reverse was true
of the MIT Romney Barack Obama campaign
right so this is something we're going
to have to be learning from some things
might seem intuitive but we don't have
enough data or experience yet to know if
they're useful signals but we should
definitely be using them and I'll just
close with some noodling Zahn on trendy
things that I haven't seen used in the
polls that would really be great and
that might be better than what we're
doing now so I haven't seen either
polling inputs or crowd sourced data
used with deep learning deep learning is
everywhere now right it's amazing I
don't really know why we haven't used it
on polling data deep learning does great
even with small amounts of data so I'd
really love to see somebody work on this
there's been a lot of interest in
identifying safe news we've already had
a talk here this morning on that I
haven't seen people using this as some
kind of input into the model but I'm
sure there are futures we can use in
addition to polling to supplement right
we can know what people are seeing in
addition to what they're thinking also
fake polls have been spotted from time
to time it would be interesting to have
more people looking for fake poll
not saying people do this on purpose but
there's definitely evidence that
pollsters might yet their poll it
doesn't look like everyone else's poll
so they sort of massage those weights
we've talked about so they're more in
conformity so if we can think of ways to
identify that behavior and maybe lower
the weights of polls coming from those
sorts of pollsters that would also be a
tremendous service to the community and
finally as far as using your Python
skills to do something about the current
political environment another really
cool thing that's been going on is
people are trying to grab whatever
government data they think is going to
be deleted from the Trump administration
I don't want to be political but I think
we all love data in this room it can't
be a bad thing to have it available so
if you want to get involved in hacking
efforts to grab data and keep it on non
governmental servers that's something
else that you can think about doing so a
quick summary and wish list
remember uncertainty is bad it hurts
people economically they lose their jobs
it's not a good thing polling related
behavior is drastically changing we
can't necessarily blame pollsters for
this but to the extent we can build
tools to help them account for this or
to find new ways to get data inputs that
would be really helpful there's work to
be done in novel polling environments
like Twitter right if we start thinking
about what people are saying not just to
pollsters of inputs that would be really
valuable really no one has crashed the
crowdsourcing problem people have tried
it with financial markets or with
betting websites those things did
terrible with these two elections but
certainly there must be some kind of
wisdom in the crowds for example one
pollster actually did really well by
asking people are your neighbors voting
for Donald Trump rather than asking them
and that whole star called many states
that others didn't right so if you start
asking people what do you think other
people think rather than what do you
think that might be another way forward
and that's another thing we can see on
Twitter right we can do it cheaper on
Twitter than with live call so if we can
find a way to translate that into some
kind of web scraping that's going to be
really powerful and then finally we read
it we need to rethink public
communication I don't think posters did
a bad job but we have to do something
different so that people aren't leaving
these nasty comments on pollsters
websites right you can't have a
situation where pollsters are even
saying this is within the margin of
error but clearly people didn't get that
right so the extent we can do new data
visualizations or new tools to make the
election results some more polling
results more accessible
that would be great so thank you very
much for your patience I apologize for
running over I think that's a very
interesting talk one thing you mentioned
Twitter quite a few times but don't you
run into the Reader's Digest problem
that you have a very biased son or the
courtesy to the users are presumably not
representative population I mean how
could it be information even on how big
the bias is certain types of information
so you're talking about biased selection
in what scenario using a Twitter
sentiment analysis or anything like that
to get a feel for how the population
might vote you are something from a
biased population there soon so you mean
sampling from Twitter yeah yeah I know I
entirely agree but in that case because
we've had such a large amount of data I
think that we can learn what the bias is
as opposed to when we're sampling from
Pennsylvania for three months and that's
already costing a lot of money we may
never be able to discover the bias until
it's too late and I expect the 2020
electorate will be very different from
the 2016 electric so I'm not sure we'll
learn any lessons whereas with Twitter I
think of it as this you know continuing
conversation humanity is having you know
one hundred thousand tweets from
Pennsylvania every day I'm sure is a low
estimate and so in that way yes you have
bias but you can probably quantify it
pretty well and it's probably not
changing nearly as much as it will just
from 2012 to 2016 it's just a way to
defeat this problem of only sampling
every four years
yeah only on the same topic of Twitter
bias isn't there also a danger that if
pollsters do start using that sort of
information then you're going to get a
flood of Twitter BOTS sizing it the fake
information to try and boost their their
candidates polling ratings and how do
you compensate for that
yeah and that's so there's a few things
I want to say let me put them on my hand
so don't forget so the first thing as
far as identifying bots that's a similar
problem to identifying fake news I think
it's an even easier problem but I
shouldn't say BOTS your obvious right
because I might have the false negative
things going on if I've decided that's
another bot so it must not be a bot
right and that's a bigger and bigger
problem and in fact the other day I was
just talking to a friend he was
commenting that it's not clear if the
Turing test is a real test anymore
because I think BOTS can fool me
sometimes and so there's that
I think bots will be easy to identify at
least the really awful ones just like
fake news that really awful news should
be easy to identify
I don't think polling organizations even
either news media or private polling
companies are currently equipped for
that polling is huge money in the US and
yet when you look at the staff not to
criticize but it tends to be people with
political science degrees people with
law degrees and then maybe one software
engineer which worries me because I
think that even if they get their hands
on some NLP prepackaged
software and run it through they're not
going to have the skills to identify
bots and I think they're starting to
understand that and they are starting to
do more technical hires but not enough
and that's where the extensive Python
community can be proactive in building
tools like a bot identifier for Twitter
that's an easy github API that everyone
can use and at least send posters can
say well we use Twitter and we use this
open-source package and then we can be
intelligent consumers because we'll know
the limits of the software they use so
that's one thing and then as far as the
biased sampling I have to tell you later
because I forgot but it was it was
interesting so I want to tell you sorry
thank you for a very interesting
presentation and I was wondering if you
could talk more about what kind of
things can be done after the election
when you have identified what how do you
then say what kind of errors you had and
how to integrate that into your analysis
oh yeah so and again I apologize that
this has been such a u.s. slanted
presentation I wanted to do more UK I
found fewer materials and it's less my
area of interest but in the u.s. one of
the frustrating things is the data that
you need to figure out what happened in
the election is really spread out so
eventually all states will publish their
measures of who showed up and they
actually will tell you the names when I
first started working on the campaign
and I found out that it's actually
publicly available my name my age my
race where I live and how often I voted
I was a little creeped out because that
feels a little bit like a threatens
democracy right like my not who I voted
for obviously but the fact that I voted
is public information so states are
required to publish that certain states
are required to publish the race because
their civil rights era
problematic states so you can find out
who voted and that's helpful because you
have everyone has models of who we think
is going to turn out versus looking at
who actually turned out so that's one
way that your turn out models can get
better turnout though is also something
that was really different in 2016
compared to other elections for example
lower educated White's turned out it
much much higher rates than they had in
a very long time the black community as
a whole turned out at much much lower
rates than they had in a long time and
so there were all these things that
changed people had some sense that they
would change in advance but only once
all the states published their data that
we're really going to know if that's
true and it's really up to each
individual pollster to go back and look
at their own models they will probably
have published this by the end of 2017
but for example even up to now not all
states have published that data as far
as figuring out how people voted right
which is the other parts who's going to
vote and then how they're going to vote
that's private except for what they tell
you there is this weird effect that
people tend to tell you they voted for
the winner at a higher rate than before
the election they said they would write
so they do these follow-up polls but
that number tends to be stable so Pew
Research every year
calls people about a week after the
election and they call them the day
before the election they do this
follow-up and it's only about 10% of
people who change that was the same this
year as always so that behavior seems to
be about the same so it seems from that
as though we can guess that people were
not sampled appropriately but again we
have to go and see who voted and then
we'll know whether we sampled them so
there's the who voted data and then
there's calling them after the fact and
those are really the ways that pollsters
can correct themselves there is always
is the question though also with polling
of I took a snapshot in time but I'm
actually saying this snapshot for maybe
two weeks ago or two days ago before the
election is what's predicting the
election and that's also a little bit
weird right because people just
naturally change doesn't mean they like
lie to the pollsters it just means they
had an evolution of preferences or maybe
they went in and like truly they didn't
know who they were going to vote for and
they just sort of looked at a name and
pushed it right some percentage of
people will do that too so there is some
randomness and some history dependent
assets that you just can't capture
entirely but yeah I mean this this is
why for me like something like Twitter
is much more the future because we can
learn much more with polling I think
pollsters do their best but there is a
very low ceiling to how well they can do
and how much they can learn less
questions hi thanks for your talk I just
had a quick question about sampling
weights in that respect you ever think
about a model of strategic voting where
while you're doing the polling how does
that affect in turn people who see the
polls and change their voting according
to the polls
I mean you is there do you ever take
into account models where the weights
change with that so as far as I know no
professional pollsters do that and up
until recently they've been pretty well
justified right so again going back to
the US examples because we have this
weird system like one thing that people
used to worry about is if you announce
the exit polls for the East Coast before
the polls in the West Coast have closed
is that going to change the West Coast
there wasn't much evidence that they had
so for example in Ronald Reagan ran they
did release polling results on the East
Coast before
West Coast had closed and West Coast
tends to be very democratic so there was
a thinking that a lot of people had just
gone home and not voted they couldn't
really find evidence for that as far as
whether Ronald Reagan won the state but
they could find evidence in what we call
sort of lower ballot decisions right so
the Senators and the representatives on
the Democratic side didn't do as well so
in that sense there is some evidence
that seeing turnout or Election Day exit
polling does affect people's behavior
they've done the same thing looking at
polling more in advance and have not
found for example that how well someone
is doing changes their vote intention
now that said there haven't been these
sort of predictive models that are all
the rage now that are covered in the
news that people of two hundred million
people going to see nate silver's models
that had such strong results right even
when Barack Obama was running for
reelection nobody was giving him 90
percent nods so there's also the problem
that maybe at some point you get to a
threshold where the psychology changes
right if I'm a busy person in Florida
who might have voted for Hillary Clinton
but I see she's going to win it's like
95 percent sir and why would I waste my
time and so that's something actually
even just this year some political
scientists have been writing academic
papers about whether that happened and
they're coming out 50/50 so it's
something that's always hard to figure
out but it's something where people are
also saying maybe there's some there's
some obligation professional obligations
either not release or if you're going to
release something that says 90 percent
you really have an ethical obligation to
explain what that means thank you thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]